你的心里的话，
你要给自己一个定义，
我是愿意这么窝窝囊囊，
委委屈屈，
心里不健康的当一个外面的人夸一句的好女儿，
还是愿意当一个心理很健康，
很洒脱杀伐决断过自己的日子，
追求自己的人生的这样一个主体性的女性。
那我小时候吧，
我的父亲就经常爱打牌，
或者一些家庭的琐碎，
所以小时候爸妈这块经常吵架，
等我大了以后呢，
我2012年毕业找一个工厂上了四年班，
在上班的过程中，
我爸就经常给我打电话，
家里也有矛盾的时候让我回家去调解，
每次我一说他的问题的时候，
他就给我发火打压我，
说我出事不行，
回不了社会什么的。
但其实到为子女，
我都是想让父母把这个事解决嘛，
那会儿我就暗下决心说不回家，
离家远远的，
这个时候处了个对象，
到最后我失恋了嘛，
然我就到了隔壁城市，
到了16年，
在外边的时候待了将近两年吧，
也挺好的，
攒了300来块钱，
当时我爸正好也是没找到合适的工作，
就在家待业，
待了两年，
一直玩游戏，
这个时候我赚了钱，
他们也给加补贴，
机缘巧合下遇到了一个机会吧，
因为他有销售这一块的，
他就想创业，
一直他在家也不干活，
所以我们。
我妈这个时候觉得他找到事业了，
并且我爸给我打了好有次电话让我回家，
刚开时他给我打的时候我就拒绝的，
后期我妈又给我打，
说有可能发展的也比较好，
比在外边上班时强，
我妈给我打电话的时候我就比较心软了，
我就给回来了，
等于在被动的话境他回去了，
这个时候有一个追我的，
想着也到了结婚年龄了，
我也就选择结婚了，
并且家里现在这个时候也需要人和我一起在家里干，
我把存了3万多块钱，
包括当时结婚的是5万来块钱就投入到生意上了，
结婚的时候也没有赔嫁，
当时家里是给我的回复是没有钱，
两年的婚姻因为感情不合就给离婚了，
现在开了一个门店，
生意慢慢好了，
但是和家里那个，
当时我爸是做销售，
是做饲料啊，
他是做的水貂，
我他明年是做的这个猪，
我来问你吧，
你第一段婚姻那个时候刚开的时候没有孩子是吧？
对的，
是没有孩子了，
现在你多大年纪了？
九三年32岁，
现在又进入第二段婚姻了吗？
还没有，
现在你做那小店大概一年收入是个什么情况啊，
应该是十来万，
那挺好的，
现在自己手上有多少存款呀，
有个五六十特别棒，
还有一段是在二二年的时候。
在外边考试，
因为我之前学历不高，
我是中专，
我在外边提升了一个大专学历，
在外边考试的时候吧，
我现在我和我爸的这个关系矛病点特别大了，
我发现他一出，
我是在外边通过监控看到的嘛，
因为这个事儿，
我回来以后，
我就通过我的这个方法找到了这个女的地址，
我去找他以后，
那个女的好像对我很了解，
我就感觉是我爸跟他说的很多，
她也很高傲啊，
当时我们两个人是动手了，
动手以后对方就是报警了，
本来我是想着不和我妈说，
我不想让他生气，
因为他挂钩以后，
这样我全家就知道了，
我爸也没有瞒着他，
当时闹的，
我爸就觉得这个事是因为我当时都给我动了剪刀了，
他和我妈平时吵架落的时候他就经常摔东西，
也动手，
所以现在哈，
我感觉我跟他接触在家里特别难，
我这几年也很焦虑，
白头发也都出来了，
我现在就感觉和他是不是没法在一起合作，
我现在就是不知道是继续杵着门店好，
还是我要单独出去好，
如果你自己单独出去，
假设你再开一个相同类似的门店，
还能挣到一年差不多10万块钱吗？
如果这个人你再有红心吧，
我感觉出去的话，
就算是个别的行业，
我感觉10万块钱来就赚了，
如果是这样。
啊，
咱们有这样的能力的话，
尽早出去，
为什么呢？
我的感觉是这样啊，
父母之间的矛盾还得找女儿回来评评理，
这件事情的话，
就在我看来父母就不太靠谱，
是啊，
我现在有这种意识，
那你就离得远一点，
本来你爸确实也不靠谱，
还在外面找别的女人是吧，
你不要掺和你爸和你妈之间的事情，
他俩愿意过是他俩的事儿，
他俩不愿意过了，
他俩愿意怎么着了，
你不要搀和他俩，
但是我爸现在哈，
就问我，
你妈是不是有经理资金，
让他要是有这资质没有的话，
他这样我说他做不了爸爸，
因为他是做的他的行业嘛，
爸爸有些他经手的有一些欠账，
他现在就说他精力不够了，
如果我不干门店的话，
她也开不下去了，
这个门店外边那个策划想让我去收，
果我说不上来，
他也慢慢招成经力去慢慢接收，
并且我还有个妹妹，
她今年刚毕业，
我是为一个老大，
我不知道现在是何去何从，
包括我的自己的主体，
但我也找不到了到底哪条路是对的，
包括我，
我平时说话他也去了，
说口定。
我个人的性格啊，
生而为人，
我们是拥有充分的自由的，
我有迁徙的自由，
我有选择跟一个人产生深度链接的自由，
也有选择跟一个人不要深度链接的自由，
尤其是在现在这个社会，
本来压力就很大，
一个人想要维持自己的心理健康。
你是需要付出代价的，
像吴志红老师说，
你想要心理健康，
那这件事情要付出代价，
这个代价是什么？
从此之后，
你再也不是那个有口皆碑的好人，
在你的心里的话，
你要给自己一个定义，
我是愿意这么窝窝囊囊，
委委屈屈，
心里不健康的，
当一个外面的人夸一句的好女儿，
还是愿意当一个心理很健康，
很洒脱杀伐决断过自己的日子，
追求自己的人生的这样一个主体性的女性。
你要做出抉择的就是你在家里面，
本来你跟你爸关系也不对付，
本来你爸也不靠谱，
在外面别的女人，
本来他们关系都成这样了，
是吧？
你能改变什么呢？
你改变不了什么，
这是他们的人生，
这是他们的因果，
也是他们两个人的纠缠。
你改变不了，
你只能尊重。
如果有一天你妈妈想离了，
你不能说妈，
我给你请律师，
我给你出钱，
不，
你妈妈想离了，
你说我尊重你，
你要是没饭吃了，
我可以给你饭吃，
你没地方住了，
给你提供一个住的地方，
但是你的决定是你自己做的，
我尊重你，
那如可以给你看，
我现在32岁，
如果说我还守着没店的话，
我爸给我的建议是你现在还有一个老板的头衔，
你找对象的话，
你再坚持一年，
找对象头衔会好一些，
你觉得这种建议可取吗？
还是说我，
但是我问你啊，
人生建议，
你听你爸的人生建议，
请问你爸的人生过得很成功吗？
你爸的人。
过得很璀璨吗？
过得很幸福吗？
你怎么还能考虑他的人生建历呢？
你想啥呢？
我现在有点迷茫，
那到了这种人生路程出去比较好是吗？
我认为是这样的，
你只有离开你爸爸这种有毒的关系，
内耗你的情绪的关系，
你才有可能自己去滋养自己，
才有可能有一段好的姻缘。
否则的话，
你爸爸某种程度上他自己过得不咋地，
还想掌控你的人生，
没错吧，
他自己过得稀巴烂，
他还想要指导你的人生，
瞧不上这种家长，
自己乱搞自己啥啥啥也不是，
还想掌控而你的人生，
那龙菲姐，
我现在这个人生牌已经打的挺烂的了，
其实并没有，
姑娘你并没有，
你才30出头，
你有几十万的存款，
你有赚钱的能力，
你有成为自己的可能性，
其实你现在这个状态挺好的，
你没有乱生孩子，
没有创造一个不幸的灵魂，
你挺对自己负责任的，
就是哪，
就说未来的话，
你想就要怎么走呢，
离你爸远一点，
努力挣钱，
在挣钱的过程当中去找寻那些志同道合的人，
人要主动一点，
但凡看一个你觉得工作很踏实啊，
合作起来很愉快，
多问一嘴，
你结婚了吗？
为啥他们两个女孩子就是大大方方的，
我看上你了，
这句话没有那么难，
我自己打算是，
你看我这个现成小。
别人父母远一点儿，
但是我又活不下我妈妈，
你妈妈如果有一天受够了你爸爸，
他没有生存能力的话，
自然而然会来找你的，
还是要自己变强，
自己离开现在这个地方，
等自己有就能力了以后，
才才能去保护妈妈。
我跟你说姐妹这句话是真理，
你现在存款只有几十万，
等你存款到200万的时候，
你跟你说气质都不一样，
语气都不一样，
跟你爸说话的话，
你眼神都会不一样，
好吧，
嗯，
好，
那就这样啊，
谢谢大家啊，
姐妹们，
你们一定要相信龙飞，
当你有了存款之后，
你看他现在有几十万的存款，
当他有了200万存款的时候，
有了300万存款的时候，
人的气质会不一样，
跟他妈妈说话，
跟他爸爸说话的角度会不一样，
而且你越有钱，
你存款越多，
你的爸爸对你造成的影响会越来越小，
因为你深深的知道，
你比你爸强，
你比你爸靠谱，
你比你爸有能力保护自己，
记得点赞关注哦。